welcome Julian and Nico they're here
today to talk to us about using Thompson
Thompson sampling and self-learning
models to improve targeted advertising
so how we welcome them
[Applause]
all right cool thanks for the
introduction so
um I made a quick overview of what we're
going to talk about today uh first of
all a very brief company introduction
probably most boring part but well spend
about one minute about that then to
briefly set the stage is uh to talk a
little bit about personalization and why
it matters uh then I'm going to focus a
little bit about uh the car
manufacturer's case study this this
introduction part will take about 10
minutes and then we're going to dive
into the most interesting parts from
Nico take over it's about Thompson
sampling uh multi-fried Beijing and the
results about that so the large part of
the talk will be about the statistics
itself
uh finally we'll talk a little bit about
the results of what we did uh and
briefly touched on some future research
and improvements and hopefully we'll
still have some time left for questions
so really quickly company introduction
and it's not a promotional talk here but
we are here from group M we're also
sponsoring this event uh and basically
uh we are in the media industry media
industry so group m is basically an
umbrella organization and Benitez is a
mind share media commissions wavemaker
and the Netherlands Greenhouse I don't
know if some of the people may know
Greenhouse here because I think uh We've
also been quite present here in the past
here but we are rebranding as for next
year largely into group m uh so what we
do is largely media investment media
strategy but we also have a quite a
strong data science and data not
technology presence we managed 60
billion spend globally wow a lot of
money but it's not our money that we
make it's the money of clients that we
spend so it's not our income
um uh we have 41 000 employees globally
and we're active in 80 markets so we
hear from the Netherlands representing
that
um so first thing first let's talk a
little bit very briefly about
personalization I I think it's for many
people here you've probably read
something about a new specialist all
developments within gdpr privacy Etc
that's uh becoming more and more
relevant and a little bit about the
client's challenge before we dive into
what we actually did for the client
I I mean one slide over this but
personalization is I think becoming more
and more important in our industry in
the advertising industry uh consumers
expect Brands to demonstrate that they
know them on a personal level and it's
just some very brief statistics here but
we see that when marketers are able to
leverage personalization uh they see
actually on average about 20 in sales
when they use it in the right way
Shoppers are also more likely to buy
something from from a company that
offers personalized experiences and
consumers a large large set of consumers
they have recommended or chosen or paid
for brands that actually are for them
personalized experiences so it's
actually growing right now people are
really expecting this
however when we look at our industry we
see that many companies uh are really
not leveraging that opportunity right
now and I know this chart is not like
something that's very backed up by data
it's very average but what we see is
that
um what we want to do is we want to run
as most effective campaigns that we can
for our advertisers possible so every
all the marketing budgets that we spend
for advertise we want to get the best
Roi of every Euro we spend for them and
obviously when we can Target our
consumers was the best product and the
best offers that we have then that's
that then we achieve that but what we're
seeing right now that most companies are
not doing the right way so the the most
the most targeting that they use often
is like social demographics so they're
targeting maybe personalizing based on
hey who's male who's female sometimes
maybe they're targeting addressing a
person by its name but obviously we can
go much further than that but when we go
further on that it requires some more
advanced things you have to think about
technology but also algorithms Etc and a
lot of data is being involved and most
companies that don't have the
capabilities to do that at scale and
actually it's quite a big opportunity
that we were in it's booming right now
and that's why we're investing in this
um and then one more slide so why is it
not easy and obviously did this doesn't
cover all but it's just to give you like
a brief introduction first of all uh
data foundation so when you want to
personalize you need a 360 degree view
of your customer that requires often
that you need to integrate quite some
different data sources to get that 360
degree view of your customers so often
that data siled in either a CRM
databases you need qualitative research
you have behavioral data you have Market
data so you need a lot of data you need
to integrate to get a good idea about
what your customer prefers
then when you think about
personalization you can have a strategy
hey you have a one-size-fits all I reach
all the people with one ad or you think
okay I'm gonna deliver a specific ad for
one specific person but when you even
are achieving that then you also need
um digital Asset Management that follows
that meaning that you have to have an
individual designs that meet those needs
of all these individual customers this
can also be quite challenging and also
costly
then thirdly I think you also require
technology to achieve that first of all
to manage all those different data
sources so thinking about data warehouse
and data legs or customer data platforms
dmps and Legacy you need supporting data
to have that and also to deliver those
personalized experiences
via Dynamic content optimization
platforms
and fourthly and this is the focus of
the talk uh you need an intelligent
decisioning mechanism algorithm to also
decide okay what I'm going to show to
what customer at what moment or what
time and to have some logic behind that
and not do that based on Expert judgment
so the common challenges we see with
this is that and I think I touched upon
those already a little bit is that the
data required for Effective
personalization is often trapped in like
lots of silos we experience we work with
quite some large advertisements and we
always see that we wanna if one Central
view of the customer most advertisers
they don't have the data in one Central
room they have it in a lot of different
places
then the decisioning logic is often done
based on Expert judgment and even if
they want to build an algorithm or then
usually they don't have the capability
on how to do it themselves so they need
to go to third parties or they come to
us
then what I mentioned the design Parts
okay so nice that you are missioning to
to start this personalization but it
also means that you have to develop a
lot of different assets which can be
costly and also the experimentation
programs to find out if it's working or
not is also going to be quite intensive
um and lastly the technology part often
is not even available or they are like
underestimate requirements to even get
those experimentation programs running
and what technology requirements are
associated with that and they don't have
the investment ready to do that or they
don't have the technology yet
so having said that I want to make a
brief jump to the car manufacturer's
case study just that you guys have an
idea for in case you didn't have so
what's associated with this so what we
had was a car manufacturer called X so
these are images of an Aston Martin so
it's not Aston Martin that we did it but
I found these nice images on Google
which look nice and it fit right really
cool on this slide so uh there's that
um and they have quite a large range of
car models and they want to deliver that
to a diverse set of customers on the
market so again maybe Austin Martin
would not be the best example here
because most people that buy that car
are rich right so Volkswagen would be
better but I didn't find nice pictures
but anyway to attract these new
customers
um where they had no previous
interactions with
um they had quite a large budget
available for that to reach those
customers and the way they did that is
with display advertisement I'm not going
to go into it into detail I don't know
how many marketeers on this room but
this may advertisement are those
annoying banners that you see either on
the web or your mobile or scrolling and
you see these banners popping up that's
what I use for that
um this client also and shockingly many
clients don't have they had no
understanding of the distinguishing
characteristics of preference or
attitudes of customers that drive unique
purchase Behavior so what do I mean by
that
um obviously also sitting here we don't
have one group of people people here
have different preferences we have males
females but we have different jobs we
have different attitudes different
preferences one like this one like that
so people can be segmented in groups and
they have basically no idea about all
these different models and you would
expect
the factory producers model was like
okay we're going to produce this and
then this model because this fits this
one customer this and this and that but
they had no idea and this is something
we see with many customers
so what they ask is okay so what we're
going to get want to get a better Roi
for marketing investment so we helped
them with the question so how can we
advertise the right car model with the
right message to the right customer at
skill
so what they had now as a legacy said
about the current setup was basically
the optimized or showing the best
performing car model
to one large audience and was performing
here I mean that was calculated okay how
many clicks they got on that so but now
they were focusing on one large audience
so there are a couple of challenges here
but first of all the way they did it now
was for an A B testing setup so in this
example here you see three cars they had
more cars but it's just an example and
the way they did that is that they
rotated these three cars equally for a
certain amount of time until they had
enough data points
to say okay one car performs better than
the other car calculated in the amount
of Impressions it showed and the amount
of clicks they got out of one of the
cars so if one guard amount of more
clicks than the other and then the
others compared to the Impressions okay
these cars apparently more likable than
the other ones
there was a couple of challenges with
that the first one the most important
one is obviously I think that there is a
large opportunity cost here because
let's say that one of these cars would
indeed perform much better than the
other ones then we have had a quite a
long time that we have shown
underperforming assets too or large
audience in the time we could have shown
better cars higher performing assets
the Second Challenge we have in this
part is that they are assuming that
there was just one audience and that
people don't have specific or different
trades or unique characters of of their
behavior that make them prefer different
models they just have one big audience
and the the third part here is that they
don't think about uh the different that
they they assume that the only
differentiator that drives performance
is the model itself but not the way we
present the model to our audience
because for example
even though in this audience some people
may lack the same model the way you
maybe find that model appealing was
maybe I showed to you uh the USPS of a
car being safe or car having like boot
space or on the other hand some person
may like that the car hasn't like a fuel
efficiency or as electric or as energy
friendly in in these terms saying so
it's also important and that's like key
interacting obviously how do we sell our
product it's not okay I like this
product not marketing it's all about
emotions how do we sell the product
so what we proposed in this slide may be
a little bit difficult to understand but
I'll take you through it
so what we propose is different so we
want to optimize showing the best
performing concept and concept meaning
concept A variation of a card a
variation of a banner talking like
showing emotions in a banner so what how
are we going to present the car that's a
variation
of the best performing car model of the
model to the Right audience so you see
we also defined diff different sets of
audiences here uh
um for the people
so in this way if you do it in that way
it's going to be a different design and
there was a couple of things that that
we want to touch upon so like I said
like first of all the thing is I gave
you the example of
um that we feel like what was missing
was the differentiator and how are we
presenting the car and I gave you the
example like hey let's say somebody here
likes a BMW one person may like the BMW
okay but why do you like it and why are
the appealing that you pres that you are
present to it some people just like the
looks of it and some people say okay I
like a BMW 5 series because this car has
certain technology in a developers but I
also like the 5c but I value it for a
different purpose so we found that that
differentiator in is very important
and second of all
um the problem that we're going to see
here and that's very important to
consider in the first slide before you
saw we had three different models and
that means that we have three variations
to test against each other and I already
said there are already opportunity costs
arising there when we have three models
because I've showed one model is
performing much better than the other
then we have like let's say 66 percent
that's like underperforming now in this
case we already see like we have mod
model on the top second model below and
we made three variations of that model
so what happens here if one of these
models is underperforming or much better
performed the opportunity cars are going
to be even higher here so we had to have
to we have to think of okay how we're
going to fix that and how we're going to
do that efficiently so meaning so we
want to learn in between so we want to
learn when we run our advertisement also
when we learn that one model is being
performing better than the other we're
going to be able to exploit that
simultaneously to make sure that we Bank
let's call it Bank on those learnings
immediately yeah and the right hand you
see okay but also wasn't High positive
us obviously and that's a very important
hey we are not targeting one specific
audience now we're going to think about
different audiences because people have
different straights and the most easiest
way that you can think about hey we have
males females but there are many ways we
can segment audiences and we'll touch a
little bit on that in the next slide
so the final slide before we go into how
we did it is very briefly high level is
get high over approach summarizing what
we did
so first of all as I mentioned
um it's very important to think about
the consumer and the different traits
that consumers may have
so we did we leveraged qualitative and
quantitative research quality of
research meaning we had service of
research agencies that actually asked
people okay when you buy a car so what
do you like when you buy a car what do
you value when you buy a car so is it
pricing is it security is it fuel
consumption different things that we
looked at
so that's what we looked at
um and we identified what are these
distinguished injectoristics for this
brand that drive differences in purchase
Behavior then we also validated that
those different differentiations in that
purchase Behavior those these segments
of groups that also vary between models
of cars so in that way we already
justifies okay we see
um the the segmentation of the audience
department so the trades are apartment
also the types of models that are
important
then we built a personalization
algorithm in between which Nico will be
touched on a little bit and based on
step one and two we also defined this
testing hypothesis based on that
research so the hypothesis could be hey
we feel that there is uh that to achieve
performance also the grouping of uh the
segments of audience is important and we
feel that the models is a drive so
showing different models as a drive for
performance but also the traits of these
groups is important
and finally I think about I'm not going
to touch upon on that obviously I talked
a little bit about technology being
important to deliver that to our
audiences well the algorithm also needed
to connect with our dco algorithm dco
standing for dynamic content
optimization we have a group member
Lodge
a large technology vendor that offers us
for us we need to make sure that the
algorithm automatically sends signals to
the technology to build to deliver Those
ads at scale
having giving this introduction
hopefully it was understandable for
everybody here I'm going to give yeah
everything here to Nico who will tell a
little bit about how we did this with
the algorithm which is actually the
focus of photograph today
hey thank you Jillian
um actually I'm Set uh thank you and uh
sketch sort of the outline of this uh
the problem which we had with kind of
different issues and the
um
yeah the setting which we are working in
and first I'm going to start with yeah
sort of the start of the algorithm which
is the Thompson sampling part
um yeah Thompson sampling is coming from
one specific problem which is the
multi-art Bandit problem which some of
you might have heard about as well is
sort of a problem between explore and
exploit
um the question which was raised was
okay if you have for example a few slot
machines and uh I have I want to get the
best payout out of these slot machines
how do I actually approach this issue
um especially if you want to know which
slot machine has the best payout and you
can test this in many different way for
example just take a slot test once a
slot machine each time and one which
gives you the highest payout you choose
that one for eternity but of course
that's probably not the right right
approach another way which is use a lot
in the industry entirely is for example
maybe testing which you take like a
random
sample out of each of these for yeah a
certain period of time until you're
certain enough that you have the right
slot machine
however this solution is also not
optimal actually then also mentioned
earlier you have yeah you're losing out
on a lot of opportunity where you could
have served like a better
um yeah you've got a
uh chosen a better result machine in
this case
um and here I have a little bit of an
example about it for example at the top
you have like a b testing you see at the
left like you have three thousand draws
in each period And if you do that in a b
testing way then you have three thousand
uh you have 1000 for each front end so a
b and c and then at the right you see
yeah number of wins about it which is of
course constant over time in these
different periods as well
um at the bottom you have an example of
Thompson sampling it's not the exact
approach of this but it's more of an
illustrative example where you see that
at the beginning you have again
splitting it in three different ways so
33 for all of these and then slightly
when you get more and more confident
adding more
um
it draws to the variant which is
actually performing better already and
as you can see then on the right that
the total number of wins actually
increases over time as you get more
confident because you're showing the
yeah in this case Bandit which is
performing uh
exploiting the Bandit which is
preferring better and better each time a
little bit more
um yeah as you can imagine this is sort
of a risk reward trade-off as you at the
one end one two yeah
explore exploit the best performing one
as much as possible that at the other
end don't want to end up with a losing
or a worse performing one
um
a b testing as I said before
solves this trade-off by yeah not taking
any information in it entirely at all
and randomly distribute these different
roles so taking no written at least
amount of risk as possible
um Thompson sampling solves this issue
by actually giving each variant a sample
rate which is equal to the probability
that that
um yeah that that's a specific for Ryan
is going to be a winner
um and this yeah online gives a little
bit of uh it gives each variant a chance
to show if they're a winner or not and
on the other hand slightly increases the
percentage of sort of the best
performing ones which you're going to
show
um however in practicality you need to
estimate this probability of who is
going to be a winner as well
um and a good way to estimate this
probability or who's going to be Winner
Is by you in a with a Bayesian approach
in this day case and you can do this by
estimating each different for the
distribution of the verbility of a win
for each different variety
um and in the case that you have like a
binary payout so you have a win or a
loss a good distribution for that in
this case is the beta distribution as it
has a really nice property that if you
add the
um you're using Basin law to add new
wins and new losses to your information
then you still end up with a better
distribution in this case
um
in this case here on your right I have
an example where we have the first
variant being having Five Laws five wins
and 95 losses and the second one having
10 wins and 90 losses and with this year
on the right you have this simulated
distributions of these two and as you
can see it's with this you can also
calculate okay what is in this case the
probability that variant a is going to
win over RnB and in this case you have
for Friday a eight percent uh probably
to win and RnB 92 percent of probability
to win so in this case you will also
show or will choose that that front end
98 or 92 percent
um yeah as Thompson sampling is in this
case great for
um yeah minimizing regret or maximizing
right in this case and sort of random
solution however it does it also has its
limitation it does not necessarily
decrease the time which you need to test
until you reach a sort of significance
or until you reach the point where you
decide okay this is the best friend
which you want to continuously serve
um
and if you have like quite a large
number of orions and especially also if
you have a very low probability of
someone of winning then this is going to
be take a lot of time or a lot of tries
to actually reach yeah good results
and that's why I also want to touch a
little bit about the solution which we
use in this case for it which is
Thompson sampling with yeah what we call
multifarite Basin
um
yeah so what you don't already explained
um we have in this case uh we had three
different segments and uh two different
models and four different concepts so if
you can imagine then we have 24
different sort of variants in which we
wanted to test which is already quite a
large number and if you scale this even
further up in bigger tests then it's
impossible almost to test this with a
beat testing
um
that's why Yeah we actually wanted to
use sort of our prior knowledge of
um the things we used in the setup
um in this model itself
um and these prior knowledge are sort of
the preference for the model the
preference for the team order concept
and a largely finally sort of the
similarities across different segments
um and we did this by looking at it in
two different ways we have here a sort
of the action which you want to take so
what do you are you showing to the
people
um in this case it's the model and the
concept itself and the second one is
sort of the context so in this case it's
the segment it was in this case for the
eight segments
um but in the context and also in the
action you could do many different
things for example for context it could
also be the platform which you're
showing
um
other kinds of characteristics of people
as well
um and yeah to incorporate these sort of
three different concepts for one
specific variant we use so-called
hierarchical weighted priors which
um yeah use the information of sort of
the overarching context for that
specific variant into that specific
context
um however we to have this similarity we
incorporated only the
forions or the sort of overarching teams
which were yeah mathematically speaking
one distance away in either the action
or in the context
um and we'll give a little bit of an
example after this
um
and this way only varians which actually
are sort of close to the origin of range
which you want to test give actual
weight to the prior itself
um so for example in this case if we had
like these eight different frames where
I had two different models two different
concepts and two different segments then
we would look at
um
these different groups and we'll slowly
go through them
um so in this case the first two are
again the action and the last one is the
context and the p in this case is sort
of the probability that that variant is
the probability of the foreign having a
win in this case
um The Vines which we are we in four
different groups in this case and it's
mostly looked at by sort of the distance
which they have to the original for info
in this case b11
um and there's different groups and then
in this case looking okay uh the total
group of all variants which have like
the same model with a different context
but again the same same segment and the
second one A different or all models uh
but uh and the same concept and finally
as well the same segment as well and the
last one having sort of two distance
away which is one switch is all kinds of
models but a similar concept and a
different segment and finally as well
the ones which have uh yeah similar
model but it might have different
concept and segments
um
if you then look at all the different
variants then you can see that all the
greens ones are the ones which we
actually use are bernoullas for but the
red ones are the ones which we don't use
at all in this case but if you think a
little bit about it some might have a
little bit of a more wave than others
because they're already closer to the
original variant
I was looking at all the time I'll try
to beat it up and probably skip past the
results as well
um
what we then do is each of these
different
um
groups we need to give them a sort of a
weight as well and by the way how we
look at it is okay
one group one group can have a certain
distance from the specific variant so
this group has a same also a sort of
amount of wins and losses just as the
specific variant and then we look at
okay how far away is that group from the
specific variant itself and then give
that specific weight to the prior for
that for Ryan so for example if a group
is very far away distribution of
speaking from that for iron then we
don't give him any weight at all or very
very low weight and if it group is very
close to that specific frame then we
give it a much higher weight or rate
very heavily
[Music]
um
and also have a little bit of example
for it what it does actually is that
over time you actually start with the on
top situation where both the variant and
the group still have a lot of yeah
certain uncertainty about it and
um in this case as well you can see that
there might be a little bit of a
difference between the variant and the
group itself but their distribution
speaking still pretty close
however and this way the group already
gets a lot of weight into the specific
front itself however over time
um the distribution developed more
towards just the bottom distribution
around where you can see that yeah the
distribution way smaller in this case
you had a group almost doesn't
contribute to a specific front itself
anymore
um which yeah helps you with sort of
start it gives you a better start for
the special friends in knowing what kind
of distribution this probability would
have
uh I don't know if
I don't know if you have any more time
or
okay
um yeah and also ended up at results I
unfortunately need to skip this probably
um very shortly we did a first test in
this case well where uh we actually saw
that there was some uplift
um a bit more interestingly what we saw
that there was a difference in what
people actually liked
um
and also what we saw is that sort of
assumptions which we had that the
different groups or this model and
variant actually held up as well so
models overall which are performing
better are performing better also over
variance itself and also with the vine
which was performed overall better is
also performing better over the
different models in this case so it was
nice to see that yeah sort of our
assumptions also met as well otherwise
the entire previous part would have been
for nothing
um
yes I also get all that for it and thank
you for your time and your attention and
let me know if you have any questions
[Applause]
that's true
yes so
yeah so the question was if
um
in some cases like a b testing
compared to a b testing to Thompson
sampling and the question was if a b
testing in some cases still was referred
to than Thompson sampling and there are
so in these some cases especially if you
want like it is preferred if you
actually want to know
more specifically what is how each for
the variety is performing we can imagine
that for Thompson sampling you are
putting less and less sort of effort in
one in the lower performing variants and
if you do that then you're also have
yeah less knowledge about that specific
variant as well so if you want to have
sort of equal knowledge about all three
of the different varieties and it would
be preferable to yeah show all three of
them equally in this case
yeah
uh so the question was if I could
deliver it a little bit on the python
packages which are used
um in this case we used
um mostly numpy packages and we have
tried it as well with by MC3 but because
we wanted to more quickly
incorporate this in
um
yeah calculate these kind of
distributions we needed to actually sort
of manually
sample these different uh
uh hierarchies because yeah the prime C3
can be a little bit slow in some cases I
think it's a great package in general
but it could be it can be a little bit
slower especially if you're adding more
layer sort of yeah I should say
very good question so
is it odd or not do you hear me okay so
the question was where the information
comes from the segmentation so uh yeah
in this case in the difference per
client that we work for in this case the
client itself had it and cantar as a
research agency did it so it's basically
qualitative qualitative research which
they ask a large sample of current
customers of this car manufacturer they
asked them about a lot of things so
first of all age gender income household
status where they live Etc but they also
ask a lot of attitudinal questions
towards what do they prefer when they
buy a car what they value what's
important so it's a combination of that
then that quality of research we also
plotted on their actual sales data and
we managed to build those segments
does that answer your question
okay
but it's a very good question because I
hope it wasn't clear from the talk
because
obviously in algorithm is as good as
what you put into it and it starts with
a certain assumption or hypothesis and
we base that on actually research
because if we didn't have to recharge we
made some random audiences up that would
have probably come something out of it
but you could question the relevancy of
this of this case so I think it's very
good to start with that research
good question so the first question was
if I used online training
um
I think you mean it only
trained gallery
it no it that's
we didn't use that specifically in this
case
it's quite hard to
in general already sort of gets the
information of a specific person and
secondly it would take a lot of
computational power as well to
like for each for Ryan for each specific
creative which you show then calculate
what a new probability would be so we
didn't use online we updated like the
model every or the probabilities every
day in this case which was enough as
well
uh this question was about the most
predictive context was it not like any
code uh the boot space Etc versus the
elderly people I don't know if that was
his question but it's more like yes we
noticed that for example for elderly
people in a very extreme example we
noticed that younger people valued a lot
the way the design and the car looks and
elderly people and there's one dimension
we look at they were more involved for
that specific model about whether they
had like a car that they could step into
easily that could carry a lot of
passengers weight and also the designs
were also focusing on those USPS and
showing the boot space of the car
whereas younger people are more
associated with okay how do I look in
and how does the car look itself yeah
perhaps perhaps a good one is this graph
here which I didn't come to where you
can see indeed they're like in the air
where people are a little bit lower age
you can see that distributions are quite
close to each other where for also 35 to
55 55 plus there are more differences
between the different Vines as well
the good question so do what extent do
we track individuals data
we don't track individuals
directly as in we gather data mostly of
if we've shown a certain variant to
someone and if what sort of if they
clicked on it or not
um
and
um yeah of course for the different
segmentations it's mostly coming from
yeah the display platform itself I
honestly personally don't know exactly
which where they try how they built that
platform itself
um but there probably is some tracking
involved in there where they you need to
segment these people into different
segments in this case itself
yeah exactly
evaluate
Education Works
yeah maybe to add to that this was
first proof concept as a final note the
client's kpi in this case was ready to
evaluate it and click through
to Virtual and click through rate
I can imagine that people might argue
okay from the marketers here it could be
top funnel advertisement awareness kind
of ads maybe you want to development on
a different kpi we're looking into for
example building this model on for
example view time uh that how long the
people looked at the ad that data for
this client was not available so we
worked with the kpis that they gave to
us but
um yeah that's I think a valid question
okay thank you very much I think if
anyone has any of our questions I'm sure
you can chat with uh Mr Drake and uh
thanks for the wonderful talking to you
and Julian
[Applause]